le président de la république
la visite d'un président devant le
congrès de la mutualité c'est une
tradition
mais pour jacques chirac ce matin
c'était bien autre chose tout le monde
guettait la première sortie publique du
chef de l'état depuis la défaite des
sillons les jce est surtout sous le
regard de martine aubry et bernard
kouchner deux de ses nouveaux ministres
la visite s'inscrivait sur le terrain
social mais d'emblée le discours a pris
un tour politique jacques chirac a
défini son rôle dans la cohabitation
aujourd'hui mon devoir c'est de veiller
à ce que chacun a sa place et respectant
l'autre nous servions tous ensemble des
intérêts et des valeurs qui nous dépasse
nous unissent aussi et qui font tout
simplement les idéaux de la république
au premier rang desquels l'égalité des
chances la morale civique la vertu
républicaine
aujourd'hui mon devoir c'est de
préserver les acquis européen obtenue
après 40 ans de patience et d'efforts et
de jacques chirac qui se désigne dans le
même temps garant de la protection
sociale
la cohabitation semble débuté sous de
bons auspices
des républicains des démocrates je crois
qu'il a surtout rappelé l'importance de
la cohésion sociale et la protection
sociale en france
3.4 d'accord avec ces propos chacun veut
donc je de la décrispation et le
consensus apparent au moins sur
certaines questions comme la santé avec
cette répartition des rôles
le chef de l'état donne les grands
principes comme l'égalité de tous devant
la médecine sur les problèmes de locaux
effectif en revanche il laisse son
gouvernement à agir sur que le ministre
espère avec ce soir c'est encore avec
une femme ministre celle de la culture
catherine trautmann que jacques chirac a
procédé à la réouverture du palais des
beaux arts à lille après six ans de
travaux décidés en son temps par
françois mitterrand le président qui
avait initié la cohabitation et qui
inspirera peut-être son successeur